i hope you enjoyed our sessions today
which covered the latest developments in
bringing responsible ai to the real
world
as you've seen through today's sessions
the issues at the intersection of ai
systems people and our society is a top
priority for us at microsoft
we made a public commitment to
responsible ai as early as 2016 by
sharing our responsible ai principles
as researchers working on responsible ai
we've learned quickly that sharing these
principles is the easy part
bringing them to reality through the
design and development of our products
company-wide policies and compliance and
partnering with policy makers is the
real mission we are committed to
the way our responsible ai work has
evolved as a collaboration between
research product groups and our legal
experts is a great example of research
influencing our company
today's session showcased our work on
this mission the session on advances in
fairness and ai discussed the state of
the art in fairness research and what is
next
the responsible ai toolbox showed how
research on fairness air analysis and
transparency is making its way into the
hands of developers today
tools are only useful when they are put
into practice the tutorial led by amit
deshpande provided best practices for ai
development today working on real
problems is a great way for us to
uncover new issues related to
responsible ai and it's a great way to
fill our research
the panels on content moderation and
language technologies discuss the
important issues uncovered by today's ai
systems
we recognize that challenges around
developing ai responsibly are not only
technical but they are socio-technical
therefore the approaches for addressing
these challenges need to put people in
the very center
in their tutorial selima murshi and
michaela varnamono presented the human
ai experience toolkit which supports
human-centered ai design
recognizing that the true value of ai
systems will come from human ai
collaboration our last panel of today
brought together experts to discuss the
future of human ai collaboration
we'd like to thank you for joining us
for the responsible ai track we hope
these sessions have demonstrated our
passion for developing ai responsibly
the way we are working as a company on
this mission and the challenges and
opportunities we see ahead
going forward we'll continue sharing our
work with the rest of the world through
publications open access tools and
resources which we make available
through microsoft responsible ai
resource center
we look forward to hearing from you and
learning about your thoughts and
experiences on working on responsible ai
or if you're interested in working
together with us through one of our our
open positions
we hope to see you at another microsoft
microsoft research event soon